So as I said earlier, what we're dealing with here is two equations this one and
this one that have one common term which is money spent. We just said that we
can substitute money spent with money spent each month times the number of
months whenever we want to. So that means that this quantity down here On the
right side of the second equation, can be moved up into this slot in the first
equation. Having done that substitution now, we can see that the amount of money
that Grant has left is equal to the money from the founders - the money spent
each month * the number of months. If we look down at our answer choices, that
is The third choice, so great job on this quiz whether you got it right or you
didn't. Like I said earlier, I know that this is a lot of writing to look at on
the screen at one time, we're actually going to address that problem in just a
second.